[Music]
i got some good news to start the show
finally some good news for lindsay lohan
it's about time for her don't you think
good news
today
a los angeles judge told lindsay lohan
that she's doing great with her
probation and will soon be in the clear
isn't that nice yeah
yeah then
yeah that then the judge looked down and
said hey who stole my gavel
i didn't take a gavel i took this hammer
thingy though
controversy for adele did you hear about
this after being cut off during her
speech at london's brit awards yesterday
adele gave the finger to the show's host
get him the finger yeah yeah the host
was so bummed out he went right home and
listened to his adele album
did i just mind putting a record on
i think you did wow that's embarrassing
i meant put in the eight-track right
crank up the victrola
borat star sasha baron cohen has been
banned from the oscars
yeah
the producers are worried that if sasha
baron cohen shows up something
interesting might happen
and that is not
allowed by the way though those oscar
people got that when i did
oh yeah the old brown boy sure
during a concert at the white house
yesterday did you hear about this
president obama got on stage and
performed with mick jagger yeah
apparently obama wanted to prove to
republicans that he could work with a
rich old white guy
due to a new law requiring adult film
stores to wear condoms the porn industry
has started to leave los angeles
yeah you can tell the porn stars are
planning to move because they've been
posting ads on craigslist for extremely
used futons
and uh yeah
you don't want to be taking that thing
home with you
yeah there you go oh
dear
oh oh
fire extinguisher
[Laughter]
the world's most insecure mime
walking against wind
i'm in a box
today newt gingrich
said we should use covert operations to
assassinate iran's nuclear scientists
yeah
gingrich also said the key to covert
operations is announcing them on the
campaign trail
[Applause]
[Music]
taco bell is in the news taco bell's
coming out with a taco that's wrapped in
a dorito shell
yeah if for some reason that doesn't
sound appealing to you you're not stoned
right now
so you you just outed yourselves by the
way
that's the best
[Applause]
i haven't listened to one thing conan
said so far
but
chris brown you know chris brown is in a
twitter feud
with a professional
wrestler yeah yeah the wrestler
threatened to body slam brown but brown
said hey we're not even dating
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you looking at nothing yeah you
know i got left you always stand there
looking at me with disapproval that is
not true it is true it's my distrustful
german eyes
i can't always hear acting like a fool
doing whatever i can to keep this show
going
and you're in the corner of what i need
is
what a carrot talked clown